Another Thing That Doctor Bright is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
He’s no longer allowed to challenge Able
to unwinnable games like tic-tac-toe.
It was three weeks before Able conceded a draw.
It probably shouldn’t surprise you that Able,
legendary swordsman and component of SCP-076,
both takes himself very seriously and
has a bit of a competitive streak.
That’s why Dr. Bright enjoys getting under
his skin by challenging him to pointless and
unwinnable games like tic-tac-toe, just
to watch him get steamed. The problem is,
when Able gets steamed, there tends to
be a large amount of collateral damage.
That’s why, during containment breaches.
Dr. Bright is advised to keep himself
and his snakes and ladders board
well away from the affected area.